it's become a daily routine waiting for
drinking water in the city of mikolai in
southern Ukraine ludaclau says the water
in the Taps is contaminated
bombs are destroying us the water pump
was attacked near her son so we're
without water now there's dirty water in
the Taps we can't use it to cook food
only to wash our feet and use it to
flush
six months ago Russian forces tried to
capture Miko live the Ukrainian Army
managed to repel their attack and push
them out of the city but people like
Alexandre hokovicina continue to
struggle
I won't go anywhere this is our land we
will stay here
I thought that because of my age I was
going to have a nice life but no every
day there's shelling
but it's not just the water thousands
have been forced to leave the area
's house was destroyed by two Russian
Rockets his family have left the country
but he says he had to stay all men of
fighting age are banned to leave the
country
they had attacked before but no one
expected that this area would be
targeted it's not clear what they aim
for could be the factory behind but you
see they target people residential areas
and there's no guarantee Russia won't
try to take the city once again
Rockets continue to be fired on the city
reducing homes schools and Healthcare
facilities this used to be the
traumatology area of this hospital and
as you can see it was completely
destroyed authorities say that around 10
000 buildings in the city have been
damaged by the shelling
the streets look empty except for
barricades made of tires that show how
the city is ready to resist a Russian
occupation
authorities are struggling to restore
electricity and gas supplies before
winter
the Russians will not pull back they
won't stop however as of today we have
everything in order to face them we will
meet them and fight them we won't give
up
while the fighting goes on in the
Southern and Eastern parts of the
country Millions have managed to escape
but many others are reluctant to live
it's their home they say and their need
to remain here is greater than the
constant dangers they face
Ukraine